[Music]
well Universal kedusha woody yeah Roger
Oh Monty I'm looking over to watch a
laser
Tony Allen DeGeneres all the Argentine
tango simulator tomorrow children
whether Pavarotti a row with a cobra a
20-car foucha John Mearsheimer shop
there are copied over to much Suzanne
Jana tells you do double duty on Susanna
fatal of water will your children should
say how they harder play well welcome to
the challenge here just a woman hold the
internal Ernie accustomed to life which
is the throat accustomed to serve mine
with a one-time my mother
trigger wash my mother take a Hamza
module that is who are use it to know
whether the quality it's a way to how
that drove our yellow channel woman
tivo'd Eagle young little girl you go to
me the new moi urusai wants uncommon
either children come on idea Tasha woman
the teachers are kind of curvy
shillelagh fish
- what is your return from other judges
even don't cover so much
Jochen a year George are you take Amir
Amir Agha Lisa the baby they take a poo
front all the other
yeah I'm telling you type woman younger
day he broke down weather so turn a
woman come on you make another one which
is hanjiro oh my daughter you got the
target
[Music]
start from Santa
mean hombres Alejandro Olmedo su can't
endure año para el condado incessant a
quarter Pais por todo el mundo que le
monde Torah ego oh damn ese Chico
vinyasa Sarah opera schwa as you go la
gente Disqus absurdo can pero para que e
K tau pero es increible porque la gente
le gusta
[Music]
todos los lunas Akina Sangamo restaurant
a cantamos a las siete de la noche opera
invitamos mo siempre Cantante z-- y VN
Sopranos burrito nos been ORS ya samos
una Buena Fiesta aqui y la pasamos
mara-vee-oso
[Music]
antes de estar en este restaurant a
estaba en Rusia cantando por varios años
con take in en toes Cuarenta siete
concierge porto Rusia como en siento
cincuenta ciudades MP second on equip or
que esto yo estaba Cena ser nada de
pronto yah no tenían concierto de choses
habla de Bracy Sega Baba minima pasa we
get echo say hey a / de bello her
hobbies middle alejandro nonchalant a
subiendo so chumby omaha eres un bien
sûr amigo toss in guro so llamo any
Hasina's have a ninja hamada by konami
on for Angela Diigo so and ah ha men so
pal Cimmerian young goodra Chavo solo
sing off the hello crud clone you dengue
ha cocina de mi hermano koreana
[Music]
me mejor amigo numero uno es hoy y muy
contento me Travis is kg de que yo Tenga
sa treble a hoe de cantar e DV my beer
de la opera le my canto sega alessandro
de parada awesome had an emission mucho
mucho de todo el mundo de a so domains
invaded or a hollow Picciotto yo cuando
canto un gran teatro canto compassion
con la verdad con todo mi corazón y
cuando canto resaurant a igual uno y
donde sia yo tengo de cantar con todo
con todo
I remember the first time we got on a
start line and it's just adrenaline
blood was pumping heart rate was racing
being on a sidecar does add the extra
dimension because you've got to work
with the person next to you having him
as my brother in the sidecar is what
it's all about
I'm Sam Halton I'm Andy happen we're
brothers and we're a competitive cyclist
team I started racing probably when I
was about 10
I'd been on a bike since four years old
I guess I mean look isn't it I was maybe
13 in that picture Sam beat me once in
the last rites that we had no yellow
deluxe he'll only ever beaten me once
yeah won my first championship with the
local club about 11 or 12 years old
Rover bike all the way up through
different championships - I was a 24 in
2005 and that's gonna have my extent
[Music]
I had an accident while I was out
training I ended up going over the
handlebars on and landing flat on my
back shattered my t7 vertebra that one
moment kind of changed my life I came
out of hospital and I spent a couple of
years without without doing much it's
only so long that you can fend off that
desire and that bug to get back on a
bike we found the sidecar and now I'm
out racing this thing which is fantastic
when I tell people that I race sidecar
they seem to assume that I'm going to be
the one in the passenger side but that's
not the case I'm on the bike the guys in
the sidecar
there's no sitting there's no sitting at
all they're throwing themselves from
left to right and you've got to be fully
able-bodied my role on the team is
effectively to turn the bike into keep
it level to do that it's a case of
chucking your way from side to side if
Andrew wants to go one way and I'm not
on the same wavelength we're not going
that way most of the time he knows what
I'm going to do as brothers you've
probably got that that relationship a
little bit closer than you would
otherwise that feeling you get when
you're out on the track for me it's what
I live for
you get it banked into a corner and
you've got the bike drifting sideways
I'm out there no one knows that I'm in a
wheelchair
no one knows you'll be one of the guys
you're a sidecar race you're not a
disabled guy and just an amazing fear
[Music]
nearly everyone remembers mr. Rogers
neighborhood it's a beautiful day but
not everyone knows that this cardigan
clad king of children's TV Fred Rogers
was actually a pioneer who challenged
racial stereotypes and media enter
Francois Clemens Francois Scarborough
Clemens and his role as officer Clemens
made him one of the first recurring
black characters on a children's TV show
[Music]
when I started there were two three
shows period on television that employed
a black character
Francois grew up during the civil rights
movement and times of great racial
tension in the u.s. so when Fred asked
me to be a police officer Fred are you
sure do you know what policemen
represent in the community where I was
raised
and then he started talking about
children needing helpers and the
positive influence that I could have for
young children my heart open as I
listened to him he accepted the role not
knowing he would end up playing officer
Clemens for 30 years and one of his most
memorable scenes is also one of his
favorites
there are many ways
to say I love you it's a very big deal
for me to be putting my feet in the
water with Fred during a time of
segregation the symbolism wasn't lost on
Francois to say that he didn't know what
he was doing or that he accidentally
stumbled into integration or talking
about racism or sexism that's not mr.
Rogers it was well planned and well
thought out and I think it was very
impactful there are many ways to say I
love you that impact was felt by many
before Francois it was personal
I was in the studio one day that
particular day he was filming the end of
the show and when he got to the part he
said you make every day a special day
you know how by just your being you and
I swear it was like she's looking right
into my eyes and when the music stopped
I said Fred were you talking to me and
he said yes I have been talking to you
for years but you heard me today
[Music]
liquid asses a stinky liquids that
smells like butt crack with hints of
dead animal so there are these guys
Andru masters I make liquid ass Alan
Whitman liquid ass creator no head
janitor we make the world's best stink
product and they work here this is what
we call the ass factory they hated their
jobs so they followed their dreams and
started a successful prank product
company specializing in a really rancid
fart spray but they needed a name I said
so what we gonna name it and he's
getting ready to sit down he goes I
don't know lick what I asked and I'm
like that's it then something curious
happens we're making a product
specifically for pranks at first but
then we start getting calls from
military people enter Stu Segal this guy
Stu ordered from us and I've never met
Stu and that's oddly he's got a you know
a pretty neat business he really does
and he come up with idea to use it for a
triage but the fact is that it goes from
Frank product to medical field is sort
of a sort of a jump turns out there's a
secondary market for this stuff training
some of the most elite Armed Forces to
do their jobs we are a company that
replicates the environment of combat and
right now we're in a set that we built
for a medical training whoa
whoa basically before this prank fart
spray some of our best troops and
emergency medical unfamiliar with the
overwhelmingly horrid smells of death
and disembowelment that they would
probably encounter as part of their jobs
it's a very awful smell that's something
that could actually gag a maggot as far
as I'm concerned it just smells like
liquid ass back to these two jokers now
we have a product out there that's
helping military training which is a
it's great you know you know not all
heroes wear capes
[Music]